my guest tonight is an Academy Award
nominated actor and Golden Globe winner
he's appeared in dozens of memorable
films like crash Hotel Ronda
Iron Man two and three and Avengers
endgame he also stars in the fantastic
Showtime series Black Monday and his new
show don't look deeper debuts on kwibi
July 27th please welcome the extremely
talented very busy Don Cheadle good to
see you Don how are you what's going on
good to see you man how are you I'm good
I liked it you were making fun of my
hair just before we got started because
it's out of control and I apologize I
mean no no I mean I think your hair is
taking care of all of the making fun all
its own I mean especially this lick that
you have going right now look at that
see that's like a Wi-Fi antenna right
there I'm getting I'm getting 5g right
now look at that look at that I look
like the little girl in a dr. Seuss
cartoon who comes who wakes up when the
Grinch is there you said no you said you
showed me just before the show like
you've been you you you went with Wow
look at that braids yeah that's
fantastic
I'm will you help me I would love to
virtually give you some help
yeah yeah yeah I had this done once I
was up when we did a week of shows at
the Apollo Theater some women there I
went into their shop and they braided my
hair and I've never felt pain like that
in my life yes yes I have mad respect
for people that can get good can do that
yeah it gives you a fate like a natural
facelift it just pulls everything up yes
I did look like I was sort of in my late
20s but I was in constant pain so I'm
never doing that again let me ask you
how are you as a person we'll get into
you you have I know 35 things going on
right now different projects you always
do your very busy guy but how are you
doing how's your family
we're good for the most part I mean you
know I'm very fortunate that
like I said you know I live with someone
who isn't sick of me and we're you gotta
have our routine and you know dogs and
they're fine orchids have been out of
the house for a year now and they're all
they're living together actually not too
far away so we get to see them they're
like our covert partners and know we go
over there and hang out it's cool it's
cool your kids are old enough to be
living out on their own yeah they're in
their 20s now so even if they didn't
want to go I was like you gotta go so
they're yeah my kids are still very
young but I made them leave I just I
gave them each I gave him each one
hundred and twenty dollars and I said
I'll see you in a month I think that's
good parenting because at times like
lest you kick them out of the nest and
make them fend for themselves like any
good day yes I thought it was tough love
I've had some people say you could have
given them more than 120 each and they
seemed pretty young I don't I don't
think people should tell me how to run
my life I America thank you thank you
finally someone who gets it let me ask
something um I'm I'll be I'm used to
bumping into you sometimes I'll see you
in a restaurant you're always I can tell
you're someone who's comfortable
chatting with people how are you dealing
with this zoom thing because it's
problematic I agree I mean I think and
I'm sure we're gonna see some
peer-reviewed studies coming out about
the negative effects the cancer-causing
effects of staring at a screen and
talking to 10 people in boxes all day
long I mean it is very it's it's funny
because it feels in a way like it's it's
it's distancing in a way that the the
social distancing and there's just this
distancing theme that's happening and I
know know we're social creatures and we
really want to come back together and be
together and and and share space and all
that but you know obviously we're saying
the results of doing that too soon and
it's it's very challenging you know we
had some people come over a family come
over in a friend of ours come over
and everybody was in the backyard we
were all socially distanced and our one
friend lives by himself and he was
saying man I really really needed this
and it's really tough I really feel for
people who don't have that community and
aren't able to actually see people it's
it's it's really challenging right now
yeah the I think sometimes I mean
obviously zoom is is a great invention
and it works for a bunch of things and
for its show like the one I'm doing zoom
is necessary for all the late night
shows but I sometimes would rather talk
to someone on the phone then then zoom
there's this obligation now that
everyone has to have a zoom and
sometimes there's 75 people on the zoom
yeah most of them and some of them are
like shirtless on an exercise bike and
as someone else is wearing a prom dress
and I don't know it's all over the map
well what I've started to do about zoom
and and my wife is like oh you bossed up
on now and I like it I just like turn
the camera off
they're like dawn me can't see you I'm
like no you can't see me that's the
point of turning the camera we're still
good everything's gonna get done but why
do we people have to like get dressed up
and feel like they have to I hope you
didn't dress up for me because you look
good you got the that the shirt looks
nice the Hat is very very cool it's just
you hanging around the house or was this
you saying I gotta talk to Conan he's
probably the biggest star in the
business I better clean up my act
yeah I yeah that was it I got your email
liar you just went yeah yeah that one
Mel it just hand it to me you know
there's obviously the pandemic but
there's been so much other heaviness
going on in the last month I know that
you've been of activist and a very
active activist for many many years and
you take this very seriously and I'm
just curious
all right how have how the conversations
been in the wake of George
Lloyd's murder were you and your family
having different conversations than
you've had before or was it more in was
it more intense or did you feel like now
this this didn't change anything for us
we've we've known this for a long time
well we we definitely had these
conversations before but I think if
everyone has felt in intensity about
this one and it has been ratcheted up
you know mainly because of the
callousness and in the manner in which
it was you know the murder happened and
and how we were all locked down and just
watching it on a loop I mean I never saw
the whole tape actually I just saw the
beginning and the end I couldn't really
watch it but yes these conversations
have be have have been had prior to this
with my family with the community but
with my kids it was definitely ratcheted
up a lot more because you know for them
my youngest anyway is really just sort
of getting into the workforce just you
know beginning her life and really
starting her life as an adult out there
and having all of these things happen at
the same time you know you know George
Floyd was after a Matar Murray was after
Brianna Taylor was after even you know
Amy Cooper in the park so I think the
the confluence of all of those things
together with the pandemic on top of it
really made this sort of like you know
boiling point happened and then you know
we saw the lid come off and hopefully we
will continue to find ways to keep the
conversation alive I know that there
still you know protests made Portland
it's still happening all around the
country all around the world really so
it's not like people have completely
forgotten but you know human beings want
to exhale they want to let that stress
off and and and go back to what they
believe is normal but I just think we
can't we can't do that now because I
think a return to what is normal is
actually a step back it won't be just a
return it'll be a it'll be a complete
reset to something that I don't think we
can afford to do as a community
so hopefully this moment is instructive
and hopefully we'll find many many
different ways to continue this
conversation and find out how we can
really approach the systemic issue from
all different angles there's a question
I wanted to ask you that that I've been
pondering a little bit which is the role
of celebrities in all of this I think it
can maybe sometimes get a little
complicated with priests and and I I
think you feel the same way but I
thought maybe we could have a discussion
about that my feeling being there's a
fight there's a very fine line between
someone in the public eye giving of
themselves and trying to move this piece
forward and trying to help us all grow
and saying hey look at me I'm check me
out it it can flip so quickly and I just
I just wanted to talk to you about it
because I'm sure you know you have a
strong opinion about it well I agree
with what you're saying I mean it's it
can be a double-edged sword you know we
we have this platform and and we're
we're both you know sensitive people and
we are a part of the world and we
understand that we though we have this
ability to in some ways insulate
ourselves from things at the same time
we are not insulated and these are these
issues affect everyone and so yes we
want to take our platforms and find ways
to be productive and find ways so that
you say move this thing forward but I
think a lot of times what it requires is
for us to kind of step out of the way
and use the power that we have as
producers as people behind the cameras
as well as in front of the camera to you
know to push it on that and make the non
centered voices get centered and make
sure that the people who are not seen
get to the front and you know something
that I saw people were doing on Twitter
which I thought was really cool
people were just giving their platform
over to other people you know you have a
million followers you're like okay now
let's check out Debbie who's doing this
with whatever mm who's doing this over
here and they're just gonna have my
platform for for a while so I think a
lot of times our best work is done when
we step out of the way we get the
attention and then we shift the light
you know shift the focus and and yeah
it's tricky because you can look like
your cloud surfing you can look like
you're trying to go look at me but I'm
cool with saying look at me as long as
once people are looking at you don't
look at them you know sorry right okay
that's it that's a great way about that
right that's a great way of thinking of
it I like that that that because I'm
always and I also think it's be willing
to try things have them work not work
but just move move on it's that fear
that a lot of people have of making a
mistake or looking silly that gets
discussed a lot now which is to try and
if you make a mistake or if someone if
some of your friends check you and say
yeah that wasn't quite it nice try but
that wasn't quite it don't overreact and
get defensive try again yeah fail fail
better I mean I'm I'm not sure who's the
quote is I had a discussion with Eddie
escolar and if he wants to text in he
can tell us but yeah I think it's try
fail you know fail better just keep you
know just keep at it
you keep can't it's too important to dip
out and especially because you get beat
up on you know Twitter or wherever you
know that's not that's not really the
barometer by which we should be judging
how we should acting although I
understand it can be implicit influences
but we just have to continue to ring the
bell and like you said and sometimes
it's not the perfect way but you just
gotta keep bringing it yeah I always
think this has been something that's
been this issue is plagued our country
for a couple of hundred years it is the
defining you know stain on our country
that we that we need to we need to get
better we need to resolve and so if some
embarrassment on Twitter is the price
that you pay
yeah so what get up suck it up suck it
up let's talk about Black Monday
this show is terrific I I think I get
the sense you really love being this
character I think you that's the sense I
get is that it's fun because you are
you're you are flawed which I in Laureus
ways in glorious ways I can tell
watching you do this it's like oh yeah
Dawn's having fun he's having a good
time with this yeah and I have a great
time with my cast mates and and the
writers room and and our producers and
the directors that were able to bring in
we've had a lot of a lot of great
experience with with all of these every
aspect of the show in front and behind
the camera and everybody really shows up
yeah we're are because we're trying
we're making this show in five days you
know Egypt's five days which is bananas
you know it's it's it's not enough time
I think that kind of plays into sort of
the dynamics of the show it feels
frenetic it feels like you know
everybody's on coke and experiencing it
it just feels like this you know crazy
energy in a bottle and it's just and
it's fun and I think if we didn't have
the cast that we had and we didn't have
you know the ability to just run and gun
I think it would be a turgid experience
but because we're all like there and can
really play off of each other and have a
lot of fun with each other I think it
just pops I mean yeah I'm doing a show
like this in five days and there are
probably a lot of people watching they
don't understand what you what what kind
of timeline usually exists for a show
like this like it's been wait five days
is ridiculous but it does probably help
all of you feel like you're in the
trenches yeah and and and help and yeah
you it helps you feel and look coked up
[Laughter]
like you know there's never there's been
countless times when we've each had to
pull each other out of the fire you know
and and get others back in a way that
really makes you bond and I you know I
feel really close with all those guys
and we
spend time away from the set before you
know rona was on the stroll we did yeah
so it's it's really nice to have a group
of people that you feel you have a great
time showing up and if you're going to
be in the trenches you want to be in the
trenches with these dudes you have a
very different look this season I was
looking at this picture this morning and
that is fantastic
that is a fantastic look and maybe maybe
the answer for me I don't think you
should knock it till you try it around a
little bit see what the feedback is play
with it see I want to try that look and
you know that would be I think I think I
could pull it off definitely I would get
a lot of attention you know I want to
ask you I know your character plays bass
this season is that something are you
playing the bass these days as like are
you doing the method thing of I'm gonna
learn the bass or are you saying I can
fake this let's just fake it well no it
was something that I think the writers
put in because I would always go back to
my room you know between shots and you
know between scenes and I'm always had
two bass with me oh so that's right
that's they're taking that from you yeah
borrowing their borrowing Don Cheadle's
okay that makes sense now okay they're
going oh you can do that well let's try
to figure out a way to stick it in the
show and make fun of it and I was like
that's cool so no it's not they saw you
doing something that brings you joy and
they said make that part of your
character and everyone laughs at him
yeah cool you actually making me rethink
my whole experience on the show try not
to go there but we've pierced the veil
so yeah they're not cool people now that
I think about it they're not cool at all
no no no I'll talk to them I'm okay
that's not gonna do anything I won't
talk about are you uh I know that you
we've talked about this before but you
love golf
can you play golf now I would think that
would be one of the sports you could
play absolutely right it's one of the
few things that you know you can stay
socially distanced then you're outside
and you're in the elements the winds
blowing the sun's out and you know yeah
I've been keeping that up
so that's been nice to do to see the
same you know five people around this
period of time everybody's been tested
we've all like you know gotten the
negative results so it's cool to be out
and it's the same dudes that I played
with a lot you know it's Anthony
Anderson and George Lopez and Cedric the
Entertainer and Chris Spencer and deal
hugely so we're all like keep going
that's a fun group that's a really fun
group yeah we just we just laugh and
laugh and laugh and laugh the whole time
I the celebrities I hang with are the
original kids from menudo that's all
yeah they're all in there they're late I
would say late 50s early 60s now yeah
but they feel probably like they're 70
because if they have so much road on and
yeah yes and they don't get but the only
celebrities that will hang with me so
amen you got you gotta love your friends
right Anthony Anderson has been telling
people that you like to play for sort of
interesting you like to wager when you
play golf and it can get interesting we
we have had sort of a running first we
had a brownie cup which we used to play
at Pebble Beach and then we moved it
around and then because there was such a
demand to get in the cup we had to open
it up and create the brownie
Invitational which was much more relaxed
than the rules as far as who could be a
member so we actually just had another
brownie event last month DL Hughley won
he's the reigning champion of the
brownie Invitational so is use the
winner get a certain brownie no that's
not that's not the prize the winner
actually gets a trophy which is a
beautiful trophy that George purchased a
beautiful trophy no the brownie aspect
of it is both a melanin component as
well as something that must be eaten at
the 9th at the ninth hole which makes
the back nine very interesting is it a
weed brownie is that what you're saying
you know I've never
we don't have a lab out there I can't
say for sure what's in the brownie I'm
not a forensics expert or anything like
that I will say that it doesn't taste
like your traditional brownie and there
are flecks of some material in it that I
just can't identify but it does make the
last nine holes really interesting it's
probably oregano you know it does have a
very oregano a su song to it so that's
what I say it is well I hope I didn't
ruin everything for you
hey someday I'll bring the menudo crew
over we can play with you that would be
great yeah they're really God they hate
each other I stick with the original
menudo I stick with the original guys
that's me and yeah you know that's who I
am that's how I roll all right burn out
your hair will told the whole story I
gotta do something look at that can I
just stay for a second though I mean I
know people say it all the time but damn
it that's impressive man thank you
let's see it it's getting hold of a man
are you that you can still grow that
mane like anyone tuning in right now I
don't know man I don't know what's going
on anymore we're all losing our minds
but I have to say you put a smile on my
face I always love talking to you I'm a
very big admirer of yours and so it
lifts my spirits to get to chat with you
and I sure thanks for hanging with me
you know love it any time calling I'm
great to see you all anytime really well
what am I gonna say you're gonna show
this to people you know I'll take and
you'll know okay I'm coming by tonight
with my protective
oh no no he's gone damn it
all episodes of Black Monday which is
fantastic are available on Showtime and
Don's new series don't look deeper we'll
be streaming on kwibi on July 27th make
sure you check that out
Don always a pleasure seriously and
thank you thank you for hanging with me
appreciate you man thanks coming let's
do it again okay take care